why is it that the same ideological
positions are being pushed on everybody
from corporations the media Parliament
down the road from here the church right
I mean I I could the the NHS everyone is
ad hoc to a particular worldview and you
can even believe that's a great world
view and it's exactly everyone needs
equity and diversity and whatever
mechanism there is no more important
question let me give you an example of
of a problem that we're all familiar
with and the effect in this and that
example is covet y'all remember covid
and you've probably had I'd rather not
remember if you probably had covet yes
and so I think it's fairly clearly
established it's not really a right-wing
conspiracy theory it's fairly clear that
if it didn't happen it could have
happened
um and here's how covet happens so first
you have SARS one which basically jumps
from a bat to a palm Civics very well
established very nasty disease and
um
this
you know a sergeant one is a problem it
almost escapes it almost becomes coveted
and it kills about 20 percent of the
people that have it it makes Delta covid
which was a nasty disease you know look
like the common cold it's an important
problem the way science is funded
specifically science in you know
including for example virology virology
is not social sciences very clearly
scientific it's a hard science and and
in the um in the principle of the second
half of the 20th century the way that
science has funded is sort of you know
um consistent with this kind of
government by experts principle which
and the thing about an oligarchy is it
almost looks like it's no government at
all it's just like no there's no power
here it's just it's just science it's
not power it's just science you know but
when you look more closely at human at
Power there's always human beings
involved and so the result of SARS one
is that virology becomes important and
specifically bat coronaviruses become
important and the way science having
like dropped out of my PhD program but
you know some people think of me as a
computer scientist the way science works
is you get funding for things that are
important and things that matter and So
within virology basically people realize
that they could get quite a bit of
Grants by referring to this very real
problem with bad coronaviruses and they
basically said well you know this is a
serious problem uh we deserve
um a number of pounds to study it and so
they're like what if this happened again
what if a bat coronavirus emerged well
let's go and find all the background
viruses let's go to all the bat caves
they literally did this let's bring the
viruses back but the problem is these
viruses are bad viruses they don't
naturally infect humans but they could
mutate to infect humans but waiting for
them to mutate very slow and random
process
so what if we mutated them and what if
we train them what if we put if you're
in cleavage site in what if we train
them to infect you know humanized mice
what if we did this in a Chinese
laboratory with very poor biosafety
conditions you know
the Wuhan virus was not that's an
American virus because it's funded by
American Science these people were
literally funded to do this research by
American grants and so when you talk to
the you know the virologists who did
this they're like well we need to
predict the emergency well what happens
if you predict it what do you do we
predicted it all right you know and it's
like you find you know come home and you
find your 10 year old sitting fire to
the kitchen curtains and you're like why
are you setting fire to the curtains
he's like well you know there's a lot of
fires in the kitchen cooking happens
there are accidents what if the curtains
caught fire could we get out could the
dog get out so so so gain of function
and research at least in this context is
clearly a bad idea and yet this bad idea
which you know any Fool on the street
can see is a bad idea basically succeeds
in the marketplace of ideas that you
know consists of professional
virologists with IQs of 150 who've
trained for many many years to study
this and the question of why this bad
idea succeeds in the marketplace of
ideas is fundamental to the question of
why bad ideas you know rule our society
today and how we tend you know like
the difference between gain of function
research and the idea that colleges
should discriminated in missions by the
skin color of the people applying to
them you know they're both equally
ridiculous ideas right and how do these
ridiculous ideas succeed and when we use
words like authoritarianism which is
basically
um sort of an anti-monarchical word uh
we're basically looking at the sort of
the the pathologies of monarchies which
are systems very alien to the in very
opposed to the kind of oligarchy that
runs our Democratic societies today and
monarchies you know when they fail when
they're bad and any system of government
can democracy oligarchy or monarchy can
be good or bad
basic point of Aristotle when when bad
Authority when bad monarchies distort
the marketplace of ideas it's
overwhelmingly by repressing good ideas
[Music]
um and the way that we got here is very
different from that it's by A system
that promotes bad ideas
moreover it promotes bad ideas not
through a sort of conscious monarchical
plan there's no little counsel to
Supreme Elders or something sitting in a
little room saying we're gonna you know
fund this bad idea because we like bad
ideas uh that would be better in some
ways because it would be easy to get rid
of those people but there's actually
there's no Center
there's no little cabal there's no
dictatorship there's sort of none of
that there's just a system that's
structurally rewards these bad ideas and
it structurally rewards these bad ideas
first of all by separating Authority
from responsibility and so you know is
someone like you know fauci who's almost
you know a little monarch within this
oligarchical structure of process you
know and who is really you know critical
in you know sort of authorizing and
continuing this gain of function
research will never be held accountable
and so you have this kind of division
this you know when bad ideas are
accountable they are not they're not not
favored in the in the evolutionary
darwinian contest of ideas but when you
look at the way bad ideas are promoted
and it's simply enough to not have that
accountability and when you don't have
that accountability the attraction of
bad ideas not the sort of repulsive if
you think about like electromagnetic
force you have really traction and
repulsion and what happens is basically
you have these bad ideas
and they feel good for some reason
within virology for example gain of
function research feels good because
everyone's doing it it's the way to get
grants and if you say no one should be
doing this you're basically selling
saying your fellow virologist should not
be funded that's gonna be hard all right
but the thing is you know when you
basically extend that outside the
circles of experts essentially you know
when these experts are promoting
policies that strengthen power that
reward them they're like my field is
important my field is matter matter is
more must be done and then you extend
this to sort of the broader world where
does this sort of culture of of
victimology come from whether you're
looking we talked about communism
progressivism earlier and if you look at
for example the Scottsboro boys case of
you know which is promoted by Communists
in the 1930s you connect that to George
Floyd there's sort of this clear thread
there and and and there's you know
providing people with a feeling of
saying I'm the defender of the victim
you know I am the White Knight I am the
Paladin I am standing up you know for
and and you know the effect of these
ideas may be terrible I mean I think the
effect of the George Floyd riots on you
know the African-American community in
America is straightforwardly negative
it's just very clear social science
statistics massive numbers of deaths
from Deep policing right but that
doesn't have an accountability impact on
the marketplace of ideas
what impacts the marketplace of ideas is
what should you say that because you're
sorry to translate what you're saying
into simple language the people who push
that narrative didn't get the
comeuppance they should have got yes
they were not delegitimized they were
not legitimized but they felt that
positive feeling yes of feeling
incredibly good about it their hearts
felt warm they felt important they felt
like they mattered yes they felt like it
gave them meaning right and so you know
the sort of marketing that kind of
meaning which is confined in the 1930s
to a very small Elite set of like
American Communists including my
forebears basically becomes Mass Market
in you know the sort of George Floyd
experience now every Suburban housewife
feels like they matter like they're
standing up and what they don't realize
it's that is that that's a mechanism
that not only promotes bad ideas the bad
ideas displace good ideas and you get
this kind of monoculture which looks
exactly like the kind of Monaco culture
in at least structurally I'm not saying
whether you know it looks exactly the
like the kind of monoculture that's
enforced through repressive means by an
authoritarian government such as Nazi
Germany but the mechanism that basically
creates that coordination of ideology is
promotion rather than suppression it's
attraction rather than repulsion and
it's completely it's inevitable in an
oligarchical meritocratic structure of
government and so when these oligarchies
were established you had these
marketplaces of ideas you know
professors had never been involved in
government the idea that professors
should run the government in 1900 was as
absurd as saying Postman should run the
government and because these
marketplaces of ideas in Academia were
not corrupted by power
they were flat and they were excellent
and people were like okay I have these
corrupt politicians elected by you know
democracy
um terrible result you know we'll see
username democracy just as we saw using
the name monarchy but politicians are
awful they're corrupt what about these
unbiased you know experts but the thing
is you give power to the experts and
power corrupts them and suddenly they
become they develop these conflicts of
interest they become sort of corrupted
and basically when you give power to the
marketplace of ideas the marketplace of
ideas corrupts itself and you get
basically a world of absolutely terrible
ideas
thank you
foreign